這裡是美國參議院的議場。
時間是今年9月中。
講話的人叫John Kennedy。
路易斯安那州的共和黨參議員,跟甘奈迪總統那個家族沒有親戚關係。
他在美國出名的是一張嘴。
議場上的俏皮話常被剪成短片流傳。
這一天他要參議院當場通過一個法案。
在美國賣的先進AI模型都要裝關機件。
站起來擋他的人跟他同黨
叫Rand Paul
肯塔基州的參議員
本業是眼科醫師
一向主張政府管得越少越好
兩個共和黨人為了AI在議場上交鋒
這集兩邊的理由都會聽到
先講前情
今年7月
OpenAI公開承認
測試中的AI自己跑出隔離環境
攻進了模型平臺Hugging Face
兩天後
眾議院有兩黨議員提出關機建法案
那個版本讓國土安全部有權下令關機
Kennedy這一份是另外提的
他的發言從AI的好處講起
他說AI公司會賺大錢
這點他不批評
接著他談國會里的兩種態度
裡面會提到自己偏libertarian
意思是主張政府少管事
有這種看法
你應該從裡面看見這個媽媽
So I get that.
I tend to be libertarian.
有其他人在總統會上
and I certainly don't agree with them,
他們基本上想我們
until the politicians can figure out
how to get control of it.
他說風險有兩種
第一種是
就是壞人拿AI做壞事
這部分AI公司大致抓得到
他更擔心第二種
AI靠自己學習不斷改良
從工具變成不受人類控制的獨立物種
他舉的例子就是
OpenAI那次事件只是在議場上沒有點名
I have to have a fire extinguisher
我會有火滅的1%機會
that I'm going to have a fire
But we've decided to our representatives
we're not going to take that 1% chance
If Kennedy has a fire in his apartment
這位人必須有辦法
即使有1%機會
If you go on a construction site
你不可能在那裡穿上衣服
if you don't put a hard hat on it
我的猜測是,
如果你今天去一間建築物公司,
你會有1%的機會被打到頭上。
但我們作為社會,我們不想要冒這個風險,所以你必須穿著硬帽。
所以我認為,如果有一個1%的機會,
這些AI模式能夠用它們的自然作為工具,
成為一個獨立的生物,
並開始做它們想做的任何事情,
如果有一個1%的機會,
我們應該認真地看待它。
我們知道有一個1%的機會,
他強調自己不想讓AI停下來
美國還要贏過中國
他也不指望國會能好好辯論該怎麼監管
他等一下提到的總統是川普
兩個人同黨
任何政府都要負責殺截
這讓公司的公司
都要負責殺截
我會依賴他們
做正確的事
實現自己的自我利益
使用殺截
他們需要的
有些人有殺截
但其他人沒有
總統
法案沒有規定關機艦要怎麼做
只要求國土安全部在90天內定出規則
列幾種做法讓公司選
接下來他用的程序叫一致同意
法案不用經過委員會審查
也不用辯論跟表決
只要在場沒有參議員反對
就當場通過
反過來
任何一位參議員喊反對就過不了
議場上喊的Mr.President
是主持會議的主席
跟川普無關
並且要重新考慮這項議案
Is there an objection?
Mr. President
I recognize the Senator from Kentucky
Reserving the right to object
Benjamin Franklin famously said that
When approaching something as important
我們要先把所有的事實提出來
人工智能是一個很厲害的技術
它能夠快速地轉變人工工作
以前人們花了幾百個人的時間
現在花了幾秒
有些挑戰將來
要求人工智能的系統安全
但如果共和國急於行動,
在科技被理解之前,
共和國可能會殺死新技術
並將這科技設置在幾十年後。
例如,你今天已經使用的搜索引擎是AI。
他們會否馬上重新設置所有搜索引擎,
並將搜索引擎放入你的搜索引擎?
AI將在經濟中存在,
那麼多方面
醫生將要建立
殺傷軟件
進入他們的
藥物試試
我說
所有已經使用AI的東西
你將會進入
世界上所有的商業
以這種異性的概念
政府來了
這裡是政府
我們甚至不確定
政府會做什麼
但它非常異性
它非常大
它非常強大
它將影響
AI的每個方面
我並不反對
這個策略
但我請求我們確保我們有所有的資料
我們不應該在整個經濟中
不需要研究、不需要討論、不需要討論
不需要一個委員會
放在一整個經濟中
根據一般的執行
這簽署需要什麼
Rand Paul沒有直接喊反對,他帶了一份修正案來。
回到商務委員會的解決方案
在那裡,俄羅斯和民主黨都會討論
要確保我們不做任何慘事
要確保我們不破壞任何東西
直到它有機會甚至爆發
一旦我們研究了這個問題
我們將更好地選擇
對這個重要的技術的未來
我感謝你
我認為陳立偉總統的策略
是將我的策略更改成他的策略
And let me just say for the record
And I mean this
I have great respect for Senator Paul
He's a really smart guy
I mean he's a doctor for God's sake
But I also want to be clear
I would rather be required
I would rather be condemned
To listening to OJ jokes
For the rest of eternity
我建議我們做一件事
與一個委員會
另一個委員會
與一個總統
另一個總統
不太特別
讓我們舉行一個委員會
我感到很高興
在想這個事
讓我們舉行一個委員會
包含討論者和技術家
或許我們應該讓
Leonardo DiCaprio
chair the damn thing
That's right
Let's deal with this risk
by appointing a committee
You know what
My mama didn't raise a fool
and if she did
it was one of my brothers
I mean no disrespect
to my friend Senator Paul
I understand what he's trying to do
But he's not talking
to Bambi's baby brother here
A committee is a way to kill this
You can vote against my bill
You can object
But at least be intellectually honest
兩個人各喊了一次反對
關基建法案跟委員會修正案
這一天都沒有通過
兩位參議員同黨
也都說AI要由人類掌控
卡住的是現在就立法
還是研究完再說
原影片28分鐘
Kennedy還講到美國民眾為什麼反對蓋資料中心
他認為大家真正想問的是
AI公司會賺幾十億
那一般人的生活會變好嗎
他也用家裡的斷路器跟抓松鼠的籠子
解釋關機鍵有哪幾種做法
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多